- You know, it's funny,
all this stuff I put out,
I'm motivated by that as well, right.
(upbeat music)
- Quick question, I wanted
to know how you learned
the logistics of actually
operating a business.
You do a lot of talks about what it takes
to be an entrepreneur, but the actual...
I'm curious as to how you learn
the actual logistics of that.
I'd appreciate the answer, thanks.
- Sebastian great question, my man.
I'm excited about this little concept.
This is gonna fill out these episodes
that are a little bit
tougher for you D Rock.
I like that you're hacking,
trying to make your life
a little bit easier.
I respect your execution.
Sebastian, by doing.
The way you learn
operations and the systems,
the logistics is by doing.
I mean, you could read about it.
My dad was very entrepreneurial,
so he's even more loosey goosey than I am
in a lot of ways so that wasn't in place,
but obviously a mentor can teach you.
But I think when mentors are teaching you,
they're teaching you the way it was
instead of the way it's about
to be in this new environment.
It's by doing the actual work,
like the D Rock's process,
how long did it take you
to edit the first Dailyvee?
- [D Rock] Two and a half days.
- Two and half days, and now?
- [D Rock] Three hours.
- I mean, it's doing,
that's how you get great
at your craft, you do.
There's no replacing experience.
And that's where a lot of youngsters,
you have a lot of talent,
you understand the new landscape,
but you don't have the experience yet.
And so you've gotta eat
shit, get real patient
and put in those two, three,
four years of tasting it.
This worked, this didn't,
this worked, this didn't,
this worked, this didn't.
- [D Rock] And would you also say
that you've surrounded yourself
with people that actually did know some--
- Yes and no.
The problem when you surround
yourself with people that know
is they come with that baggage.
But yes, I do like them
coming with that baggage.
'Cause then I could watch it.
One of the reasons I don't
micromanage my people
is cause I let them do their thing
and then I watch it and
I'm like, that's silly.
And then I break in, so
we get 87% of the value
of the tried and true and
13% of kind of the way I see.
And I'm always going
to, and you know this,
this is a lot of stuff we talk about.
We don't put a lot of this out there.
Like I don't talk really
about my strategy or my brain.
I don't talk about how smart
I am or how strategic I am.
That's where it really shines
because I'm forward-thinking,
that's just my natural state.
Real quick, let me interrupt you
before you watch your homie's other story.
This video right here is gonna
blow your mind, swipe up.
(upbeat music)
Yo, what are you sleeping?
What are you coding 'till four
o'clock in the morning still?
Holding on to your youth, I'm impressed.
I have a crazy idea.
You and I, at our best as a team
when we're just being
ourselves and just hacking,
there's such a special thing
that I've never been
able to replicate, right?
(upbeat music)
Gary V, D Rock's here too,
he's always fucking here.
Anyway, proud of you brother,
congrats on this next
chapter of your life.
Go crush it, go kill it.
One life baby, proud of you (kisses).
Just reach out to 15 people
you've been dying to do
business with and just DM 'em.
Say, what can I do for
you, period, that's it.
99.9% chance they won't answer you,
if you wanna reach them.
The point 01, it's worth it.
That point 01 life, D Rock.
(upbeat music)
- Hello, how are you?
Very good, congrats on winning.
You're welcome.
Yeah, I know.
So we've got some time
together, how can I help you?
I get it, it chopped for me for a second.
What upsets you, one more
time, you think about what?
So look, I think it's
about perspective, right?
I think the reason that I'm able to focus
is that I keep things very binary, right?
You know, outside of
the most extreme things,
health of my family, I try to make--
I try to remind myself
whether it's friendships
or back when I was
dating relationships or--
I put them in the proper perspective.
So I think the bigger thing
for you is to categorize both,
both the things that are going on
and put them in the proper bucket,
both the studying for what
you're trying to become
and questioning yourself if
that's really what you want.
And as your lack of focus at times,
just a subtle indicator
that you're doing this
'cause you think it's
the right thing to do
or you were told to do this,
or you've always thought
you were gonna do this,
but now that you're here, you
don't actually wanna do it.
Or do you just value, these relationships
or other things that are
running through your mind
even more than your
career or your, you know,
the things that you're focused on.
So I think it's being honest with yourself
that your brain and your emotions
are going in a different direction
than what you think on paper
is the thing that you're supposed to do.
And I actually think
you need to accept that
instead of fighting that,
I think you need to question
why that's happening
more so than, well, I
need to stay focused,
I've got a lot of studying
to do, to become this.
You gotta really break
down those two things.
And you know what's funny,
is I think you know that
I think you don't need
me to tell you that.
It's just sometimes it helps hearing it
from another voice, right?
Like I think the thing that
has always worked for me
is that it's been clear
crystal clear for me
what I'm trying to do.
And I've had everything in
the right places mentally,
and then it's enabled me to go very fast,
which really matters.
So do you agree with what I'm saying?
Hold on one second, I hope my...
There's a quote on my page, "one life",
that motivated you, you said?
I mean it makes you start questioning--
You know, it's very funny, I'm
so empathetic to people who--
Well let me ask you a question,
the thing that you're doing right now,
how much was that manifested
from you at a young age
or other people around you?
I'm glad to hear that it came
from you from a young age.
I would tell you that things change
and you need to make sure
you're focused on that.
Sometimes you have a picture
of how something's gonna be,
and then when you get there,
it doesn't live up to that.
And so, yeah, I mean, I am
motivated by "one life" too.
You know, it's funny,
all this stuff I put out,
I'm motivated by that as well, right?
Like I challenge myself to remind myself,
it's one life, it's one at bat.
And it rocks me and my foundation
when I think about it as well.
The other thing I would tell you,
and I think if you follow
my stuff, you know this,
you're such a young woman
and I really, really, really hope
that you deploy patience as well, right?
Like, you know, you cannot
have it perfectly click
for 10 years and still be young.
And I think a lot of people forget that.
For me early in my career
with my great ambitions,
building a liquor store, a wine store,
didn't seem on paper
like this is what's going to help me
get to all these places that I want to be,
but it was building a foundation
in my twenties and early thirties
that allowed me to build on top of.
And I still at 41 view
myself extremely young.
So keep that in mind as
well, I think that helps.
You're welcome.
I hope you have a great day
and feel free to reach out to me on email
if I can help more.
You're welcome.
Good to see you too, bye-bye.
That was fun.
D Rock's ask questions.
We turned him down.
(upbeat music)